well yesterday was a beautiful day but
if you were standing in line out there
in those warm mid 80s in the afternoon
i'm sure
got a little too warm we're looking for
maybe some record heat over the next few
days
it is cooling off nicely though this
morning seven hills you're down to 57
mountains edge to 58 aliante you're at
59 low 60s centennial hills to summerlin
nellis at 56 in sunrise mountain 59 so
we've got some cool numbers out there
even keeman check out kingman 45
54 in boulder city mesquite parump
you've got 50s
red rock as well and laughlin at 63. and
just a reminder red rock you now have to
have those reservations
before you can get into red rock either
do the scenic loop have a picnic do a
bike ride whatever
86 today it is going to be uh very warm
72 is normal 85 is the record and as i
roll out the seven day forecast
look how the numbers are going to change
by the weekend not too much over the
next couple of days in fact maybe even
setting record highs
big southwest winds friday ahead of a
very cold system that blasts into the
area
on saturday cold front and maybe even a
slight chance of showers for the valley
sunday
some snow in the mountains and 50s for
daytime highs that's
it with mornings in the 30s and that
lasts into next week so it's going to
stick around a while